so you're single and ready to mingle
yeah what about him yes
welcome to Fairhope Alabama this is the
story of five women in a small town
where your dating app comes up empty
after two swipes oh Lord
in college is my best friend Nick has a
new girlfriend
if it seems like I'm jealous maybe just
a little
[Music]
I'm afraid of being in a new
relationship sometimes you got to close
your eyes and just jump we're just
getting started when it comes down to it
we all want the same thing
real true love there's got to be
somebody out there like a soul mate
[Applause]
[Music]
I know what you're doing does that look
like just friends to you the truth is
love is complicated do you need more
kids I think so I would like to find
somebody that can make me laugh you're
talking to like seven something like
that
are you
fine now I love love
everything is so much better